all right so we knew it was coming but
today is a sweet sweet day for north
american counter-strike the esteemed
young stew of house 2000 pusher and de
fire of smokes
is about to start living evil and he's
bringing a few friends
rush is back from his break tim is back
from valorant it's a full-blown cloud 9
reunion and
i don't know about you but i'm ready for
the boys to bring home another major
okay so livers and lovers of counter
strike like the video subscribe to the
channel and turn on notifications i have
been wearing this exact evil geniuses
shirt since 2014 and even though
like the caddos it actually has aged
really well i do kind of need a new one
so click on things that give us ad
revenue thanks okay so look you knew was
coming i knew it was coming
but it's official
stewie2k after just over three years on
team liquid has officially joined the
ranks of evil geniuses cs go roster we
can't wait to show what we can do and
reveal our true potential well it's
pulled everyone away from stewie he's
the only one here first shot is his
second shot is his bomb is his as well
and he's got another one stewie just
tears them all down
it's stewie
live evil
[Music]
so why is this a big deal well for
starters because it's the smoke criminal
stu is undeniably i'd say the n a goat
so whenever he switches rosters it's
always going to attract eyes
but more importantly
because now north america can finally be
said to have two tier one counter-strike
rosters you see since covid drove
everything online
i'm not gonna say eg's been like bad bad
but with complexity going downhill and
the failure of cloud9's so-called
colossus roster
it's pretty much been liquid or bust
when it comes to north american
representation at world class events now
to be clear i am not issuing the efforts
of burgeoning rosters like extra salt
party astronauts bad news bears they've
made massive strides over the course of
the online era
i'm just saying that like when it comes
to tier one international events
liquid has pretty much stood alone
and even then they've stood
somewhat shakily the point is that now
we have two big blockbuster and north
american lineups so let's talk about
them liquid i've already kind of shed my
thoughts on in the last anatomy i think
that with shocks as veteran clutch
factor a true dedicated opera in the
form of oc
and nitro back at the wheel this could
be a banger roster
i don't know i'll have to wait and see
it's kind of a weird composition
in a good way
i think as for eg
i think that on paper this roster is
tantalizing to say the least
who's on the roster
let's break it down first there's stu
now there isn't much to say about stu
other than he's stu
but what i will say is that as superbly
dynamic of a competitor as he is i think
that playing on a roster with clearly
defined roles like this one will really
allow him to focus on doing what it is
he wants to do which right now
is lead as for who is inhabiting those
roles let's start with the so-called
wrist breaker
cirque the doors in the form of the neck
and three on long not if circ completely
rips the short presents out from this
attack now they can boost him up he's
going hunting
who did he even kill regarded right now
as i would say the best dedicated opera
in north america this bullish bulgarian
beauty has long been the pride and joy
of evil geniuses this kid is an animal
and in my opinion one of the most
explosive snipers in the game next up is
eg's other mainstay breeze who as far as
aimers go
i mean
yeah just
roll the inferno pistol clip it's
absolute chaos here towards middle as i
can't find anything but greater fashion
continues to apply pressure knife kill
coming in you do love to see that
assembler what a way to kick things off
ah just the explosive action does breezy
actually get a plant oh no the creeks
are coming the creeks are coming oh wait
baby ball
no way
oh my goodness
now for the additions first up is rush
the entry fragger whose on-point
aggression turned out to be a crucial
ingredient in the success of
complexity's juggernaut roster and whose
efforts helped cloud9 take home the
boston major back in 2018.
russia's watching the line beautiful
flick coming out from rush they're
seeking the defuse right now but no
one's covering him imagine has to stick
it rush he's gonna peek in he's gonna
get the one on four
make sure to tune in for upcoming
matches and glible
it looked at first as if rush would be
joining extra salt alongside dapps since
eg were reportedly eyeing valde but then
the valdez deal reportedly fell through
and lo and behold the boy is back on
home soil i think that rush is a
severely underrated fragger and i think
that he has been for some time
you need selfless sacrificial entries
who are sometimes willing to be fodder
for the cause and rush has shown time
and time again that he is willing to use
teamwork to make the dream work last but
certainly not least
tim
buddy
euro
the other half of he and stewie's fabled
behold self-dubbed the great wall of
china and the last piece of the boston
major reunion bundle well no the last
piece would have been tariq but i guess
you know he's
busy making his millions streaming
timothy automatic ta makes his
triumphant return to counter-strike
after roughly a year-long stint in
valorant
low hp not holding them back but
automatic with a flick shot to keep
genji in this the bomb once again
dropped in no man's land
[Music]
in spite of the fact that he probably
has a little bit of rust to shake off
tim remains a stellar secondary offer
and in my completely unqualified
unprofessional opinion
when he's firing on all cylinders
one of the best mid-round callers that
nacs has ever had oh and let's not
forget the coach
malik fresh off his top two finish at
the stockholm major with g2
malik is a legend in the french cs scene
and one of the most reputed coaches of
all time the hope is that with stewie
igling malik overseeing everything and
again such clearly defined roles
something which liquid went a long time
without having this roster will have
synergy and a sense of direction from
the get-go oh and as for what else is
going on in north american
counter-strike
it kind of seems like
it's back we've got dabs and swishers
yet to be signed orglis lined up who
might become extra salt we've also got
party astronauts and bad news bears
still going in full force
and of course complexity's newly
announced brand spanking new organic
locally sourced north american lineup
formed mostly out of ex extra salt but
with a healthy splash of furious bad
news bears and liquid complexity's new
lineup boasts almost everything nacs has
to offer composed of jt fang floppy
junior and grimm
these boys are ready to grind and
do you love to see it don't call it a
comeback but
it does seem as if nacs is back with a
vengeance most if not all of our troops
are home and dare i say
we might be seeing the start of
something great
call it copium but uh
we might be witnessing the musterings of
an actual renaissance
at least i [ __ ] hope we are
if this was situated if this was higher
in the script we could totally and it
wasn't a donut at me with like a one-day
turnaround we could totally just like
hard cut to a scene from the west wing
right with like the secretary of defense
just like looking solemnly up at you
know probably like bring it just bring
our boys home
okay yeah and the valorant logo on like
the [ __ ] map just bring it bring our
boys home